I try to be an optimist,
even in these dark times.
And one of the things
I wanted to talk about
is ever since COVID started everyone
has been trapped inside.
And you know what I say?
That's a great time to
take up a new hobby.
Look at the positive!
Great time to pick up a hobby.
So I've taken up an incredible new hobby
I am really excited to
share with you guys.
I'm going to show you in a segment called
Conan's New Hobby.
(intense music)
♪ Conan's new hobby ♪
♪ What's it gonna be? ♪
♪ Let's wait and see ♪
Okay, check this out:
I've been getting into origami.
Look at this guy, a
little frog right there.
Pretty cool, huh?
And I got a bird right here,
kind of a crane sort of gull,
and then a little, I don't know, flower.
What do you think, Andy?
They're nice, but they're
a little underwhelming.
Let's just say that.
Okay.
It's just that I'm still learning.
You know, I just started.
Well, it's just kinda disappointing,
especially after that
exciting intro package.
I just sorta expected more.
Yeah.
Honestly, I didn't know about the intro.
I didn't think they'd make
such a huge deal about it
and then they made that crazy intro.
And it's just hard to follow.
I know, well frankly,
you kinda let us all down.
(beep) you, Andy!
♪ Conan's new hobby ♪
♪ Conan's new hobby! ♪
(lightning striking)